in terms of what we are hearing coming
out
of the eu and from ursula van der lion
um oil and gas to end all together by
the end of the year
it presumably is not fast enough for you
hello thank you so much for having me
that is correct
we have been at war with russia for
eight years
and all of those eight years russia was
preparing to invade ukraine even further
and the reitaldi accumulated over 760
billion dollars
on their
accounts some of them is
frozen in different countries but it is
still enough for them to continue the
war to continue uh to kill us
so every single day when we are talking
with you
it's over one billion dollar that is
paid
by european countries to russia for gas
and oil
at this rate they will not only be able
to continue killing us they will be able
to afford one or two more wars and as
you can see today they paid for their
debt with uh uh with
their
dollars and euros so they omit their
default ones again so can you imagine
that
what is going on right now in their
financial system that it is able to
actually survive all the sanctions that
has been put beforehand
the most important sanctions are against
russian oil and russian gas and this is
critical and this is what needs to
happen however if you look deeper into
this six package of sanctions you see
that some countries will only stop
buying russian gas and oil russian oil
at the end of 2023
so when russia would actually suffer and
start feeling that it's beginning of
next year is the time when we still
think that the war will be going on and
my people will be killed
uh and
six packages sanction does not have
their most important point is ban on
russian gas
and uh i again want to tell everybody
here that uh it's less than five months
till the next heating season in europe
and hoping that russia will behave
differently uh in september is an
illusion so we need to account to the
point that russians will act even more
cruel than they are acting right now and
will have to survive without their
energy resources no matter if we would
have the sanctions or not putin will
just stop sending guests to europe
anyways
yeah and but in in terms of the
sanctions and their effectiveness i mean
there is there is the delay which of
course you are not happy about i suppose
in defense many countries in europe
would say that they have to to structure
an ability to get it from other places
so that they themselves don't suffer but
are you not concerned that even if there
are sanctions and even if these
sanctions are brought forward and are
effective
can't russia just sell its oil elsewhere
can't it just turn its eyes to the east
instead of the west do you think that
the sanctions even if they were brought
in tomorrow would actually stop
president putin doing what he is doing
in ukraine
we all know that russians uh sanctions
as a tool uh they have the delayed
impact that's true that's why we are
saying it's a little bit too late
because we know it will have to to be
six months maybe a year before russia
will actually be defaulted because
before russia will actually say we
cannot continue anymore this is why we
were pushing and we are pushing for it
to happen right away so we could have
this time in our hands we know that
russia can try and sell
oil elsewhere but it will the same way
as it is complicated for european
countries to restructure where they are
buying uh oil for russia it will be
complicated to restructure where they
are selling oil and plus
if
european countries and the most
important united states will claim and
recognize russia as the country sponsor
of terrorism then everybody who would be
buying oil from them would be also
considered the sponsor of terrorism and
will be also going under the sanctions
so it will be like creating this
toxicity in the whole world this is the
goal otherwise yeah they will be trying
to survive economically as they're doing
right now
in terms of the situation in ukraine
what is the latest that you're hearing
coming out of mario paul today
156 people
that we were able to evacuate from
mariupol as of style
many of them are children many of them
have not seen the ray of light for the
last months
so you can imagine that we were all in
tears once the first group reached out
to safety
it's incredible uh progress that we have
made in getting people out there were at
least 20 attempts beforehand to get
people out and they all failed
so right now our main goal is to make
sure that we get out all the children
it's about 30 children more still there
than all the women elderly and wounded
soldiers the most complicated
step would be with a wounded soldier
because russians are not allowing them
to get out and can you imagine that with
one hand when it's united nations and
red cross efforts taking people out from
as of style and russian said okay you
can take them out in the same time
they're throwing missiles at as of style
again
again doing like the same thing that
they were doing uh on the road from
marvel to the safety when they were
saying yes it's safe but then they did
not stop sis they didn't cease fire
so it's uh
it's extremely dangerous operation that
is being performed but it's also the
only way for our people to survive
because the situation inside as of style
is critical
there is still food but there is no
water no sanitation and
the conditions are really dire there
so our military will be protecting us of
style till their last breeze we have
talked to them and we know that they
will not give up uh this is their
heroism this is their uh decision to
make sure that they protect it with
their own life they know what happens to
the territories that are taken by
russians they know what happened in
bucha and they will be making sure that
it does not happen in mariupol but we
need to take out the civilians we need
to take out our women and children and
this is what we are concentrated on
it is an incredible heroism of ukrainian
soldiers who now are saying it's a
suicide mission but we are taking on
this suicide mission
here rudic uh good to talk to you in
opposition mp from ukraine thank you
very much
thank you